[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in pat 40 sports illustrated
senior writer and a college football
insider good morning pat a lot to digest
over the weekend where are you going to
start let's start with lincoln riley
got to start there i mean the biggest
like college to college coaching move i
can remember uh you know usually if
people don't leave oklahoma unless
they're retiring maybe going to the nfl
maybe a scandal chased them out to leave
oklahoma for another job
uh is remarkable and i think it says a
lot dan about where oklahoma is heading
and i'd say lincoln riley well he may be
running to
the beach in la he's also running away
from the sec and i don't blame him
yeah i brought that up and i don't know
i haven't heard but i've i just figured
if you had a chance to play for a
national championship or continue your
run
you got a better chance at usc than i
think you do taking oklahoma into the
sec uh is that fair to say though
yeah i mean i think it's fair to say
certainly i will hear what he says at
the the press conference today although
i'd imagine you know it's going to be
all about why usc is a wonderful place
which it is
but what's the one thing that has
changed it's where oklahoma is going to
make its uh its conference affiliation
and
he changed when that changed so
i i look at it and say
all the advantages that he had at
oklahoma in terms of being able to
dominate a conference recruit where you
want and who you want count less
competition less you know just
bloodthirsty weekend and week out
battles
and you can still play for a national
championship especially if and when we
get the expanded playoff which should be
soon
i'd go to usc as well how blind-sided
was oklahoma
i think they were pretty blindsided uh
you know i
i talked to somebody there last week who
who took great umbrage uh and i really i
was inquiring about lsu because that's
where the smoke was but i took great
umbrage so why do people always say that
our coaches would leave they said that
about bob stoops and didn't leave now
they're saying about lincoln i don't
think he's going to leave there's no
indication he's going to leave then all
of a sudden he's going to leave so
something at the very end of the week
whether it's friday whether it was
saturday i think things started to uh
percolate and there became a little bit
of uh turbulence there but i i don't
think oklahoma saw this coming until
very late in the game all right what's
oklahoma do what's lsu do
those are great questions uh it's
interesting to me that bob stoops steps
in as the interim and he may just do
like barry alvarez did just say look i'm
gonna coach this bowl game
uh and enjoy it and that's it
what if bob says you know what i like
this i'd like to stay i'd like to be the
head coach i mean i'm not sure that's
out of the question i know the release
from oklahoma yesterday did not say i am
only coaching the bowl game period i
just said he would be the interim coach
for the bowl game uh if not him they his
brother is doing a heck of a job at
kentucky and maybe realizing he's
scraping the ceiling of what kentucky
could do
what better place to go than oklahoma
and have the backing of your legendary
brother there who knows knows everyone
and everything about that program the
other option i think matt campbell who's
at iowa state and has had five straight
winning seasons there which hadn't
happened at that school since the 1920s
so i think that's where that list starts
lsu
i don't know man i mean mark stoops
could be in play there i still have some
people saying that they may take a
last-ditch swing at jimbo fitcher uh
there's been some talk about nfl
candidates but the lsu situation has
gotten really intriguing
all right let's look at what you think
the playoff rankings are going to look
like tomorrow night and then let's
handicap as we move into the uh the
following weekend so how's it play out
tomorrow night
i think georgia one michigan two
probably cincinnati three and then the
real intrigue
i'm sorry you probably have alabama
still in there i i would say that
whether the three or four the intrigue
to me is who's gonna be five and six and
in what order between notre dame and
oklahoma state because i anticipate
alabama losing to georgia and opening up
that fourth spot and then is it notre
dame or is it oklahoma state and i do
think it's interesting that in both of
the human polls uh the
top 25s at oklahoma state jumped ahead
of notre dame in those and so people may
be kind of setting the stage there
especially since notre dame doesn't have
another game for oklahoma state to slide
into that fourth spot if alabama does
lose the fallout from uh michigan's win
is what
it's huge i think i mean just massive
for jim harbaugh his finest day
obviously in that job something they've
been waiting for for six years
uh
they think you know and i think ever
since that fourth and one spot for jt
barrett in 2016 his program stalled and
then declined and now this shoots it
back up
with a vengeance and they're 60 minutes
away against iowa if they don't have a
letdown from going to the playoff and
let's be frank michigan has been a great
program for a long time but they haven't
been a national championship competitor
in a long time it's been quite a while
and now they've got a shot to do it you
finally get over on your nemesis you get
into the playoff you take those
defensive ends in that running game take
your chances against anybody how
valuable though do you think that
alabama win over auburn is in the eyes
of the playoff committee
i don't think it's super valuable you
know i mean it's it's
it kept them from being eliminated
but
that was a life-and-death struggle to be
to six and 16. uh so i mean i i look at
them i
i have not been that sold on alabama all
year i i would certainly have them no
higher than fourth right now and
possibly fifth or sixth uh in my
rankings i just i think that they they
are missing obviously a lot of
incredible talent from last year's team
but i think a little bit of the just
veteran leadership too that went with
that that's gotten into some really uh
some some close tough games against
mediocre competition
what if alabama beats georgia
if alabama beats georgia then i think
the playoffs pretty easy then if the
other games go according to plan it's
george it's alabama it's michigan and
cincinnati uh and then i mean you could
have an argument i suppose for oklahoma
state versus cincinnati that would be
where the tension would lie we always
got to have some tension dan even if we
got to make it up on the last day but
i if if alabama wins then the sec gets
two in and uh everybody starts
complaining about that i just got my
heisman paperwork
who
is the leading candidate do we have it's
like the mvp and the nfl i don't know if
we have a leading candidate and with the
heisman you know is is bryce young the
heisman
winner
de facto heisman winner
i don't know he was bad for 58 and a
half minutes and he was great you know i
mean
uh honestly i look at it this way is
usually
the best players on the best teams
become the heisman favorites as long as
they're offensive players this year the
best players on the whole top six are
all defensive players
george's best player is jordan davis
he's a nose tackle michigan's best
player is aiden hutchinson he's a
defensive end alabama's best player is
probably will anderson the linebacker
cincinnati sauce gardner probably there
notre dame kyle hamilton oklahoma state
malcolm rodriguez linebacker
i say let's just put it one two three
defensive players on the heisman ballot
and burn the whole place down i like it
i like it i would love to be able to
give and i've been on this kick for a
long long time i go back to when the
broncos beat the packers in the super
bowl the the broncos offensive line won
that super bowl but you can't make them
mvps
you have to give it to one person
georgia's defensive unit i mean
can we give him little heisman's
i'd be in favor of that because that's
the thing i mean like jordan davis is
the best player but his stats are
minuscule because he's a nose guard what
he does is just gum up the line and
everybody else makes the tackles
you know so yeah they i mean it's tough
to quantify and but they they deserve it
that is by far the best unit
in america either side of the ball and
really they're on like historic
record-setting pace what game you're
going to next weekend i will be in
atlanta for the tide and the bulldogs
safe travels as always pat thanks for
joining us we appreciate your time
my pleasure dan thank you that's pat 40
sports illustrated senior writer he was
at the alabama auburn game he's known as
a college football insider